aquí tenemos dos tablas por ejemplo en
esta primera nos dicen que dado algún
valor de x cuál es el valor debe elevado
a la equis por ejemplo si x vale 1.585
ve a la equis vale 3 10 más esto lo
podemos escribir así cuando x vale 1.585
entonces me quedaría que b elevado al a
1.585 esto es lo mismo que tres cuando x
vale 2.322 b elevado el x vale 5 cuando
x vale 2.807 vale x vale 7 y cuando x
vale 2.169 ve a la x vale 9 de igual
manera ahora esta tabla de aquí nos está
diciendo dado algún valor para ello
cuánto vale el logaritmo en base de bien
por ejemplo cuando lleva lean el
logaritmo en base
de a es cero cuando llévale dos el
logaritmo en base pd2 es 1 cuando lleva
el 12 el logaritmo en base b de 12 es
1.585 y este último es más vamos
escribirlo cuando vale 10 de entonces el
logaritmo el logaritmo en esta base de
10 de 10 de esto es exactamente igual
que 2.322 ok lo que quiero que hagas en
este vídeo es que pases el vídeo y
usando sólo la información que tenemos
aquí tratemos de obtener el valor de amd
el valor de a el valor de b el valor de
ce y el valor de de muy bien y ojo el
problema nos dice que no necesitamos
calculadora nos piden que no usemos
calculado
es decir vamos a utilizar solamente
nuestros poderes del razonamiento para
poder obtener el valor de amd el valor
de ver el valor de ce y el valor de d
así que es el momento ideal para que
pases el vídeo
muy bien una vez que estoy suponiendo
que ya pausas del vídeo intentemos
resolver este ejercicio lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que esta
primera tabla que tenemos aquí tiene un
montón de números para averiguar el
valor de ven sin embargo todos son la
forma de elevado a la 1.585 es 3 b
elevado a las 2.322 5 y todos los demás
así que no se ve bien que tenga sentido
a usar estos datos que tenemos aquí para
obtener el valor de ven así que mejor
vamos a utilizar esta otra tabla y que
me dice la primera columna de esta tabla
y es más déjenme cambiar de color
esta primera columna que me está
diciendo bueno si te das cuenta ahora
vale y por lo tanto me está diciendo que
el lugar es bomba se ve que es cero
déjame apuntarlo aquí el logaritmo
logaritmo en esta base de de am esto es
igual a cero ahora recuerda que también
podemos escribir la forma logarítmica
como una forma equivalente es decir esto
lo podemos leer de la siguiente manera
utilizando la forma exponencial b
elevado a la cero es lo mismo que am o
dicho de otra manera a qué potencia
tenemos que elevar a p para que nos dé
am bueno pues es a la potencia cero es
decir voy a escribir lo justo aquí esto
es equivalente a decir que ve elevado a
la potencia cero es lo mismo que a de
lujo recuerda que estas dos expresiones
son equivalentes y bueno si b es
distinto de cero entonces podemos dar la
respuesta de cuánto vale a y hay forma
de decir que p es distinto de cero
si yo le pongo aquí asumiendo que ve es
distinto de cero no lo podemos ver de
una manera clara aquí en esta primera
tabla
me es distinto de cero porque al
elevarlo a distintos valores nos da algo
distinto de cero si me fuera 0 b elevado
a cualquier valor nos daría 0 y bueno
eso quiere decir que como p es distinto
de 0 entonces todo un número distinto de
0 elevado a la potencia 0 es lo mismo
que uno es decir que a va a tomar el
valor de uno porque b elevado a cero es
lo mismo que uno y ya está ya tenemos el
primer valor el valor de a
podemos decir que vale uno de lujo que
vea la cero sea igual am bueno eso no
está diciendo que a es igual a uno ahora
utilizamos la segunda columna que
tenemos aquí en esta de aquí para ver
qué nos está diciendo y lo voy a poner
justo aquí cuando el que toma el valor
de 2
entonces el logaritmo en base b de 2 es
uno
el logaritmo el logaritmo en esta base
de 2 esto es lo mismo que 1 y bueno
recuerda que esto se puede leer de la
siguiente manera la potencia a la que
tenemos que elevar ver para que nos dé 2
bueno eso es 1 o si lo escribimos en su
forma exponencial esta expresión de aquí
es equivalente a decir que b b elevado a
la primera potencia ok esto o sea lo
mismo que 2 b elevado la primera
potencia sea lo mismo que 2 y que número
elevado la primera potencia media 2
bueno pues esos dos porque cuando yo me
tomo un 2 elevado en la primera potencia
es lo mismo que 2 y entonces de aquí
puedo concluir que p es exactamente
igual que el 2 y de lujo ya tengo otra
de estas letras desconocidas ya sé que
debe de valer 2 y entonces aquí podemos
poner un 2 y tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo porque 2 elevado a
1.585 estoy seguro que debe de ser 3
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué nos dice
la tercera columna para eso cambiemos de
color y tengo esta tercera columna y me
dice que cuando él quien vale 12
entonces el logaritmo en base b de 12 es
1.585 el logaritmo el logaritmo en base
b de 12 esto es igual a 1.585 y bueno si
esto lo escribimos en su forma
exponencial me va a quedar que ven ven
elevado al a 1.585 esto es lo mismo que
dos veces c ahora cuanto es b elevado al
a 1.585 bueno pues eso es 3 es justo lo
que me dice esta tabla fue elevado al a
1.585 esto nos da el valor de 3 esto nos
da el valor de 3 por lo tanto esto lo
podemos sustituir por el valor de 3
entonces me va a quedar que 12 es igual
a 3 que 12 es igual a 3 o dividiendo de
ambos lados entre 2 me va a quedar que
se es lo mismo que tres medios o 1.5 y
esto está quedando bastante bien porque
ya tengo otra de estas letras se toma el
valor de 1.5 y vamos a ver qué me dice
la última columna nos dice que cuando se
toma el valor de 10 de entonces el
logaritmo en base de de 10 de es 2.322 y
bueno como no tengo espacio suficiente
déjenme mover un poco esta pantalla para
poder poner aquí justo el problema ok
entonces déjame escribir aquí que el
logaritmo el logaritmo en base b de 10
de 10 de esto es igual a 2.322 ok ahora
si lo escribimos en su forma exponencial
esto nos va a quedar como
elevado a la 2.322 esto es lo mismo que
10 de pero en esta primera tabla nos
están diciendo que ven que ven elevado
al a 2.322 es lo mismo que 5 por lo
tanto esto de aquí lo podemos reemplazar
con el valor de 5 y nos va a quedar que
10 d es lo mismo que 5 o dicho de otra
manera si divididos de ambos lados entre
10 de toma el valor de 5 entre 10 lo
cual es 0.5 ya tenemos el valor de a b c
y d el valor de estas cuatro letras que
nos hacían falta utilizando solamente la
información que tenemos en estas tablas
y sin usar calculadora hasta la próxima